Ana se prepara para salir al escenario
del teatro en uno de sus viajes más
personales descendiente de cuarta
generación de palestinos sus bisabuelos
llegaron a Chile a finales del siglo XIX
sus abuelos volvieron a Palestina y
regresaron de nuevo para sentarse en el
sur del país en 1930 la vinculación que
tengo con Palestina no es solo la
cuestión familiar sino que hace un par
de años y empecé a estudiar qué es lo
que pasaba allá en Palestina Más allá de
los vínculos familiares
y empecé a sentir muchas resonancias de
cuestiones
geopolíticas digamos del casi un siglo
después de que sus abuelos llegaran a
Chile Ana forma parte de un recién
creado colectivo de dramaturgos chileno
palestinos en su mayoría mujeres que se
agrupan por primera vez para conmemorar
la fecha dramática del nagba mostrando
el teatro palestino en Santiago su obra
Palestina inexistente Palestina
Irreversible relata a través de imágenes
poemas un sueño personal largamente
ansiado el viaje que realizó a
reencontrarse con sus orígenes en 2022
la Palestina que yo experiencia ya a la
que yo vivía ya
vive acá también Pero supongo que cada
persona que acá mantiene de alguna
manera viva o vivo lo de Palestina pone
distintos acentos no O sea Hay
comunidades acá que lo organizan mucho
más desde cuestiones de sostener
tradiciones de mantener
ritualidades etcétera y hay otras
comunidades que están en otra frecuencia
respecto de eso
a 13.000 kilómetros de oriente medio en
chile se encuentra la comunidad
Palestina más grande fuera del mundo
árabe llegaron como migrantes económicos
procedentes de zonas cristianas a
principios del siglo XX en la oleada más
grande y en menor medida en 1948 tras El
Éxodo desatado por la creación del
estado de Israel se estima que hay entre
300 y 500.000 descendientes que ocupan
puestos de poder con su propia bancada
política en la fiscalía los bancos
grupos intelectuales y artístico
culturales A diferencia de otras
comunidades palestinas en América Latina
la chilena cuenta con gran implicación
política
ya chicas ensayemos por favor Omar lleva
toda su vida vinculado al colegio árabe
de Santiago donde estudió aprendió el
idioma y el baile típico palestino el
datke ahora lo enseña un grupo de niñas
adolescentes de manera colaborativa es
abogado pero dedica su tiempo libre a
seguir enseñando su cultura a las nuevas
generaciones en un trabajo de carácter
casi evangelizador que ha jugado un
papel muy importante en la resistencia
porque porque la resistencia al pueblo
palestino tiene muchas aristas entre
ellas la cultural en el sentido de
demostrarle al mundo que este es el
pueblo palestino estas son sus
tradiciones y que el pueblo palestino
continúa digamos resistiendo continúa
estando aquí y que en el fondo no nos
vamos a ir a ningún lado sus bisabuelos
llegaron a Chile huyendo del imperio
otomano en 1890 que obligaba a los
cristianos a ponerse en primera línea de
tiro en sus guerras geopolíticas sus
padres no aprendieron el idioma pero mar
se convirtió en emblema de las personas
que luchan por tener las tradiciones de
una comunidad viva se considera
palestino ante todo yo habré nacido en
Chile Pero sigo siendo palestino y Aún
estando en Chile sigo manifestando las
tradiciones palestinas por ejemplo a
través del dat que está una lucha
cultural a través de las tradiciones en
el fondo de mantener viva nuestra
cultura y digamos la lucha de nuestro
pueblo en las afueras de Santiago basada
es un vecino más en el pueblo de buin es
popular dentro de la comunidad llegó a
Chile hace 7 años como refugiado
palestino tras un recorrido por diversos
países que le negaron la entrada por su
nacionalidad el camino llevarme para
aquí
porque todo es el portas cerrado por
palestino como tengo documento de viaje
por refugiado palestino en Siria por
ejemplo
tiene todos el Puerta cerrada cuyos
padres fueron expulsados de Palestina
por la ocupación israelí nació en un
campo de refugiados y vivió toda su vida
como refugiado hasta ahora mi sangre
todos todos pero
con todos ese tiempo no vivir tranquilo
entiende siempre como como alguien entró
al mar entiende lleva Necesito una playa
para seguir vivir más
y como vivir normal hace tres años pudo
traer a su familia también como
refugiado y se muestra agradecido de ser
un chileno más
no tengo ninguno problema con nadie y
trabajo sin la vida difícil pero difícil
como otro chileno como yo vivo como
chileno
si hay comida comer si hay compras
comprar si hay plata hay como ellos aquí
siente su hogar mi gusto aquí en Chile
somos Ese primo
me encanta
vuelve para mí el alma entiende Como
centro tengo mi hermano tengo mi familia
este ese más Porta La verdad estoy feliz
en Chile porque hay comunidad cariñosa
sus raíces ni sus costumbres tiene
proyectos de construir un restaurante
palestino en este edificio junto a un
amigo mientras espera la nacionalidad
chilena para tener un lugar al cual
poder llamar también país